hey guys this is alexa ray corriea here
at gamespot i am here with microsoft
shitty as executive producer mark coats
and we are playing Ori and the blind
forest so why are we like in the forest
to begin with like what is the backstory
here am i up against yeah yeah so um
yeah the stories are really important
part of the game so basically Ori is
this allegorical tale of self-discovery
self-sacrifice and you play the role of
Oria for spirit and as you control him
an adventure through the game you're
trying to help him fulfill his destiny
destiny that he's not even really fully
aware of but at the beginning of the
game what you come to learn is that on
this mother character that has sort of
taken you in grows ill and the forest
around you also grows ill on there's
sort of this intrusion of you know
poison and decay and so you start to
notice that in the forest and then and
then your mother figure kind of takes
ill to the point where you need you need
to strike out on your own to try to you
know fix things and and that's why it
takes place in the forest some the
overarching goal is to sort of restore
order back to the unbalanced back to the
forest but along the way you find many
more nuanced elements of the story and
surfers and I'm playing as or you right
now that is already yeah so the small
little wife forest spirit is ori and
then you've already picked up a sign
which is another entity so the small
glowing orb that kind of circuit circles
ori and protects him when you press the
x button that's sign that's another
entity and he becomes your sidekick
throughout the entire adventure he kind
of fills you in on some of the
interesting background story of the
forest and kind of helps you on your way
this kind of game um it's like it's an
action-adventure platforming game right
you can tell that just by looking at it
but it's also got some progressive
elements to it in terms of as you
progress through the game you earn and
obtain new abilities which of which
basically provide you with new game
mechanics and and that then informs the
level design and creates new challenges
for you so if you think about games on
some people call this style of game on
Metroidvania so Horry is a Metroidvania
style game where while you start out
small and weak by the time you finish
the game you're actually pretty powerful
in you know sort of like a badass
character okay and you know at this
stage of the game you're still
relatively weak if you look at the gauge
in the bottom first of all we try to
keep the user interface very minimal you
know to just kind of focus on the
striking graphics and presentation of
the game but at the very bottom of your
screen that the orb in the middle as you
destroy or defeat different enemies
you'll sometimes will grab these
experience orbs and that gauge will fill
up and when it entirely fills up you'll
gain one experience point so the game
features two different ways that you
power up one is through abilities that
you obtain that you actually find in the
game and the other is by applying these
experience points along a skill tree to
kind of enhance the capabilities of your
character that way you can kind of
customize the way that you that that
already plays based upon the way that
you like to play the game to either side
of the experience gauge you'll see on
these other colored orbs on the green
side is sort of like your life
containers so in the game you'll find
these green energy orbs which will
replenish your life and yet and
sometimes you'll actually find these
larger green orbs which are sort of like
life containers so as you travel through
the game you start out with just two
life containers and are very small
therefore life gauge by the time you
finish the game you can have I think
nine of these so you'll be
more powerful terrible Wow where did you
so work what um what games did you draw
or what places did you draw inspiration
from when you were putting order
together yeah so well from a lot of
different places I mean I think I'm you
know the style the style of game goes
way back into deep you know sort of
classical gaming probably first brought
brought around by companies like
Nintendo and Sega when you think about
games like Super Mario Brothers these
classic platforming adventures you know
sonic you know games like Metroid
Castlevania etc those are certainly
inspirational in terms of you know the
type of game that that we wanted to
wanted to make Moon Studios they'll
often talk about some of their visual
inspiration coming from from animated
film so if you think about companies
like you know and creators like Studio
Ghibli um you know some other Japanese
anime creators even companies like
Disney and Pixar these are things that
that that really kind of struck a chord
with Moon Studios and they wanted to
create a game that yes had very tight
precise platforming controls because it
all starts from there but was presented
in this way that had sort of modern-day
treatment to visual fidelity and
animation and so in the game you have
these you know really vivid beautiful um
you know tight highly crafted almost
hand drawn like imagery and then you
also have this like silky smooth
animation that really goes well together
and then technically the team's done a
lot of work working directly with the
unity which the game is built upon the
unity engine to create some new
technology that allows content to be
continuously screamed and and rendered
so as you're making your way through the
world and from level to level there's
virtually no load times whatsoever so
there is any streaming and this adds to
that whole kind of vision that they had
to kind of create this almost movie like
experience the cinema like experience
and you know we think they've been
really successful in doing that and
we're really proud of what we've come up
with but you know we're excited to kind
of put it in the hands of folks like you
to really gotta be the judge of that and
this is okay so this is the ability tray
this is what I was trying the little
skill tree yep so yeah you can see like
right now you're kind of highlighting
elements along the skill tree where as
you gain additional experience points
right now you have none but if you add
some you can see that you can invest
them along these different lines of
skill and so the bottom one is sort of
more oriented towards offensive
capabilities on the very top one is is
is more oriented towards what i would
call defensive capabilities and then the
middle one sort of is almost like the
Supplemental or facilitative kind of
line of development so for example it'll
enable you later two on two to get an
extra double jump for example all right
I'll make it so that when you pick up
life you get more life than normal or
when you use some of your energy orbs to
like save the game it costs you less and
so what we found is that you know
different people like to play the game
in different ways hmm and so if you're
more offensive-minded you might want to
develop your character along the
offensive line if you're more
defensive-minded along the defensive
line and so you can kind of you have a
little bit of an ability to kind of
customize the capability of Orie
according to your liking well uh thank
you very much for showing me Orion the
blade for us how this comes out very
very soon I here yes so the game will be
coming out on March 11th 2015 so yeah
we're literally within just a couple of
months now finally getting it into the
hands and the fans and this is for Xbox
one and PC yes yo came out xbox one pc
well okay guys well I'm going to go back
to trying to climb up this wall and tune
in to do spot for all of your news and
previews